ladies and gentlemen Kirk Douglas
ladies and gentlemen Hollywood is really
the land of Oz and like the land of Oz
it has a wizard that wizard is being
awarded the most prestigious honor
tonight that this Academy has to offer
for lifetime achievement in film the
Irving Thalberg award
you know Irving Thalberg was probably
Hollywood's first Wizard
I think he'd be pleased tonight that
this award is being given to race doc
Phoebe please because Ray does what
Thalberg used to do he puts his time his
talent his money his every waking day
and sleepless night where his heart is
afraid believes in you or your story or
your ability to direct the film he'll
put all his wizardry at your command to
make it happen that's how he's given us
such marvelous treasures funny girl
funny lady the way we were smoking the
band of electric horseman Francis
Coppola first picture and herb Ross's
and Barbra Streisand and the genius of
Neil Simon's the sunshine boys the
goodbye girl California sweet in Chapter
two they don't give this award every
year you know my friend ray isn't tall
enough to make a high school basketball
team but he belongs among the Giants all
the great names of the past who made
pictures talk and sing in audience
audiences smile and dream the Irving
Thalberg zuv our town who turned the
silver screen into a world of
Enchantment a land of Oz you know it's a
great great pleasure to present to you
the winner of the Irving Thalberg award
the wizard race stock
I really couldn't have said that better
myself I Kirk and I have been great
great friends for years and I've always
taken pride in the fact and I've been
very flattered by the fact that people
say we look alike
this year I'm working on a new
arrangement to look like his son Michael
tonight's nominees have the advantage of
not knowing that they're going to win an
award and therefore they're speechless
unfortunately I've known about this for
weeks and with intense preparation I'm
still speechless
except for these notes I'm deeply moved
and appreciative that the Board of
Governors the Academy of honored me I am
privileged to have worked and with the
past four and with all of the greats
that have been recipients of the award
David Selznick Goldwyn zanuck the
Thalberg award is given for a body of
work but in my case it's been given for
the privilege of working for the body of
talent starting with years ago with
writers like Ben Hecht through Isabel
Leonard to Neil Simon and with stops
along the way for friends and mentors
like Charlie Feldman like John Huston
and so many directors actors and great
other talents we all have to make some
things so I make it to Wendy Fran Peter
fly-in Elvis tonight has been the second
most gratifying night of my life
tomorrow when I know I really keep this
will be the first thank